what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some very big and very
interesting news about Marvel Studios
and Disney specifically about Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios as
a brand new report today tells us that
Kevin feige might not be the president
of Marvel Studios for that much longer
now this isn't due to him being fired or
anything like that but a brand new
report from an Insider suggests that
Kevin feige might actually be eyeing a
different job at Disney now I know this
may be a big shock to a lot of people
and may sound extremely weird Kevin
feige created the MCU basically he
started with Iron Man and he's been
there since the beginning he also
started working with Marvel since the
very first X-Men film from there he's
worked on all of the X-Men films over in
the fox Universe the Spider-Man films
with Sam Raimi Daredevil many different
Marvel properties since the start of the
very first X-Men film so the thought of
Kevin feige not being with Marvel
Studios is kind of far-fetched however
the job that he is reportedly eyeing
would still have him in charge basically
over Marvel Studios so if you're worried
don't be too worried however I would
like to know your thoughts right away in
the comments down below what would you
think if Kevin feige moved up in Disney
and was no longer the president of
Marvel Studios now you may have heard
about this news over the past couple of
days many people have been reporting
about this and I believe most of the
headlines read Marvel Studios Kevin
feige wants new job at Disney and there
is actually some good evidence out there
that suggests that this might be true
but before we get into that let's talk
about the actual report this is coming
from Insider Jeff Snyder from the hot
mic podcast Jeff Snyder has been known
to hear some Insider information over at
Disney and Marvel Studios in fact he was
the one that told us first that Harrison
Ford was cast as red Hulk slash
Thunderbolt Ross and in the latest
episode of the hot mic podcast he said
I've heard the job that Kevin has always
coveted is that of Alan Bergman now if
you know what this job is if you know
what the job of Alan Bergman is it makes
sense that Kevin feige would want this
job it would be the chairman of Walt
Disney Studios and it would have Kevin
feige overseeing all of Disney's Movies
and streaming platforms this includes
Marvel Studios it also includes
lucasfilm Pixar and 20th Century Studios
so this would essentially be everything
literally every movie or show that
Disney produces it would be Marvel it
would be Star Wars Avatar new animated
movies if they did a Pixar movie another
Toy Story movie a spin-off if Kevin
feige was in that position he would be
in charge over all of these properties
so he would still be involved with
Marvel now here's where the talk of
Kevin feige stepping in to take over his
job comes in after Walt Disney did all
of its restructuring and Bob Iger came
back Alan Bergman was promoted to the
co-chairman of Disney entertainment
again this puts him in charge of every
everything Disney movies and shows and
also music but some insiders believe
that Alan bergman's new promotion sets
him up as a potential candidate to
succeed Bob Iger so Alan Bergman could
be the next CEO of Disney now this is
just speculation at this point this is
not confirmed however we do know that
Bob Iger is only here for about a few
years he came back to kind of help
Disney get things back in order and to
train a new successor basically to train
somebody to be him and since Alan
Bergman is essentially number two now at
Disney under Bob Iger it would make
sense that he would kind of be next in
line to take Bob iger's spot and since
he just got a promotion he's clearly
liked by Bob Iger so again while this is
just speculation at the moment and is
not confirmed it is incredibly possible
and if you put all the pieces together
it does seem likely so if what Jeff
Snyder has heard is true in the position
that Kevin feige wants us to be in
charge over all media essentially at
Disney well that position might be open
per pretty soon the role that Kevin
feige wants he might actually get but
unfortunately this would require him to
leave his position over at Marvel
Studios which is really crazy to hear
especially if you consider before that
Kevin feige has actually said in the
past that he doesn't want to be in
charge of another Studio like Star Wars
when all of the rumors about Kathleen
Kennedy being fired were going around
some people asked Kevin feige if he
would want to be in charge of Star Wars
and he said no however that could be
because he doesn't want to be in charge
of Marvel Studios and Star Wars at the
same time those are two really really
big positions to have at the same time
but they are also very different than
holding the position that oversees
everything because as president of
Marvel Studios he oversees literally
everything he is involved in all the
intricate details with every movie he's
there for a lot of the meetings he
approves of everything and he's involved
in every step of the process however if
he got this new position he would pretty
much just see it at the end yes there
would be some oversight throughout the
entire process of making movies and
deciding what Marvel Studios and
lucasfilm and other studios are going to
do however this would not involve him
being as Hands-On so whereas if Kevin
feige was president of Marvel Studios
and lucasfilm at the same time that
might stretch him too thin if he got the
promotion overseeing everything he
wouldn't be stretched too thin because
he wouldn't be as involved as he was
before and also keep this in mind even
though he said that he wouldn't want to
be in charge of another Studio he has
been tapped to produce a new Star Wars
movie and his writer for that movie is
Michael Waldron who wrote Loki season 1
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness and as of right now is writing
Avengers Secret Wars so although he is
not in charge of lucasfilm by any means
right now he is dipping his toe over in
the Star Wars universe and the reason
they wanted him to do this is because he
has done an incredible job over at
Marvel Studios the infinity Saga for the
MCU was amazing it was something that
really nobody else had really done to
the full extent that Marvel Studios did
ever before and despite what some people
would say it really did change Cinema in
the movie industry forever think about
how many other studios are producing
cinematic universes now Nintendo with
the launch of Super Mario Bros is
launching their own Nintendo universe so
Kevin feige really is in the movie
industry a legend not just in Marvel
Studios of course in Marvel Studios but
in the movie industry in general he's
amazing so the question is where does
Kevin feige Go From Here does he stay at
Marvel Studios the rest of his life or
does he have bigger aspirations well as
sad as it is to say he probably has
bigger aspirations you know he loves
Marvel you know he's a big comic book
fan and like I said he's been with
Marvel since the first X-Men movie in
the year 2000. he loves Marvel but does
that mean he won't advance in his career
of course not especially when that
advancement would still have him
overseen Marvel Studios what he loves
and do keep in mind that he does also
love star Wars and he loves the movie
industry and movies and shows in general
he's a huge fan of movies and TV and
he's done an incredible job with the MCU
so no doubt that if he did get this
position of being in charge over all
movies shows media music at Disney he
would do an incredible job and something
else to really keep in mind is that Bob
Iger really likes Kevin feige in fact
Bob Iger saved Kevin feige from being
fired by Ike perlmeter in 2015. so right
now if Alan Bergman could possibly be
the new CEO of Disney when Bob Iger
leaves Kevin feige would probably have
the votes to move into his position
after that as chairman of Walt Disney
Studios and we would be happy for him we
really would now of course this Sparks
the question of who would take Kevin
feige's spot and honestly my vote right
now would be John Favreau because he has
also been there since the Inception of
the MCU with Iron Man 1. and he's been
an executive producer for a very long
time now again since Iron Man and he's
done a lot to work for Disney in general
over with the Mandalorian and he's just
an all-around really great person so if
John Favreau could step into the
position of Marvel Studios president
after Kevin feige moves up with Disney I
think that would work out very well but
go ahead and let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below do
you like it do you not like it pour your
hearts out in the comments don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all of the latest
MCU news you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf